bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got
chrisman here today we are going to tell
you about the future of education how
are you doing well how are you
i'm doing great uh let's first start
with
uh the problem in the education system
which i think is
plentiful there's two ways that we can
do this we can either
say the politically correct stuff and
explain how the school system does a
great job
educating students or we can go down the
truthful path
which is they actually might be doing
more damage than good
which path do you want to go down i
think it's uh
you know it's important to state that
you have basically like a bad system
here that systems are separate from
people that a lot of people
you know i met a ton of people working
in the system
i don't actually know anybody who
defends the system people who work in it
don't like it they're as much trapped as
anybody else
but i do agree it's maybe less
politically correct to say but this
this uh what i call the industrial
education complex
what a system that we have now that's
that's the system
that looks like you know it's set up
like a factory right it's it's set up to
many people say this like meet the needs
of the industrial age so you get kids in
there you teach them to
follow rules and procedures most people
say that's
uh that is to train them to work in
factories and that's only half the truth
actually
part of it is to get kids to be ready to
work in factories and learn to obey the
rules and operate by a bill so you can
keep the machines running
and the other part is to teach them to
operate large bureaucracies before
the digital age like bureaucracies are
essentially distributed computers
every person in that bureaucracy is like
like a chip they have no agency
they're just meant to follow out follow
instructions follow procedures
obey the rules obey the rules is the
number one
number one uh kind of raise on debt of
that system
and now we're transitioning into the the
information age and we just we need a
new system the old one is
not going to adapt i mean i think it's
people been talking about changing it
for a hundred years now it's maybe
you know been a little bit uh off but uh
it needs a change and it needs to change
quickly
uh i have kids you know i as soon as
they were born it was like i started
kind of scheming on like how am i going
to keep them out of the system
and uh and what does a new system look
like when we have
you know unlimited access to information
and so
before we talk before we talk more about
the education system you've been working
on this stuff for a while
explain kind of your background and some
of the work that you've done so that
people don't think that there's just two
dudes up here sitting you know bashing a
system that we don't understand
yeah yeah so i um you know before
before synthesis i started uh i started
an online tutoring company
um this about about like eight eight
years ago or so
so it's a little bit uh world's not not
quite ready for that yet you had to most
of the work was just like convincing
people that you could learn online
once they did that it worked um but it
was just
it was this big you know mental hurdle
which which kovit has kind of
wiped that out now so now the timing is
is much better to do something in online
learning
um but i had uh after starting that that
really wasn't going anywhere i met uh
i met the guys at class dojo the
founders of that company which is now
yeah like a couple thousand users at the
time and it's since grown to like 51
million
it's an app for uh teachers to
communicate with parents
and so through doing that you know
you're working on
basically like you know plugging into
the existing system
and and trying to make it a little
better and and you know it does that
right like teachers can communicate with
with parents like
that makes the kids and the families
like more individuals to the teacher and
not just like you know cogs in this
giant machine so
i think that was uh you know that's like
an important step and
you know through doing that i got to
talk with probably thousands of teachers
principals administrators parents and
really kind of you know
wrap my head around the problems with
the system and and you know the
opportunities and
you know eventually kind of came to the
conclusion that i would be just didn't
didn't really fit my personality
right like i i'm more like let's blow
things up and start over let's rethink
this from
from first principles uh so i spent
about eight years there
and uh ended up meeting josh my
co-founder when i went down to uh visit
at astro school which is the
school that he built with elon musk on
the spacex campus and uh
that kind of started the process of you
know getting my mind rolling on the next
thing
so class dojo is in a generalized way an
evolutionary approach to improving
education what you're doing now is much
more revolutionary it's much more
disruptive and kind of changing of a
paradigm
versus just simply improving in small
steps the existing system
um inside these schools it's pretty
insane
like i don't think people realize again
like what happens on a day-to-day basis
and
um you know when you and i first started
talking like the first thing that hit me
in the head was i always joke that like
i don't know first grade through like
maybe they still get you to do it in
like eighth grade
it's literally you put a finger over
your mouth and you put your finger in
the air and you walk down the hallway
right uh
and it's just like this weird thing of
like be quiet
sit still do what we tell you uh and the
entire purpose of you being here is so
that
at the end of the year you pass a
end-of-year test
and if we do that that's successful uh
it doesn't matter if you actually learn
anything doesn't matter if you had fun
nothing like why is that the model
it's the logic of the industrial era
right where human beings are
are just kind of like items to be
processed right and it's
it's uh it's dehumanizing to everybody
involved like but
particularly i think the real damage is
done to the kids because you're just
you're essentially like trying to grind
down
their humanity so they can operate
within this larger industrial system
and you know now the world the world's
changing like that that old
that path might have actually worked for
people like it it did work for people if
you put your head down and you follow
that path and you went to a good college
and you get a good job at a consulting
firm or on wall street or as a lawyer or
something like that
it's not not a bad way to go you could
get uh you you could do well like that
you could
buy a home you could raise a family and
you know maybe it's not that bad but
it's the world's not that way anymore
it's actually you take you what you're
doing
you're you're an individual no one can
do exactly what you do you do this weird
mix of things that like nobody
predicted and there's more and more that
is the way
that's the direction of the economy it
feels like the old system is built to
teach people
what to think not how to think is that a
fair kind of framing of it
yeah i think i think it's it's uh you
know really
they're trying to get you to rely on on
authority
right like there is some authority and
they're going to be able to give you the
truth
and you know independent thinking is uh
is not something that's valued because
that
that blow up the industrial economy you
need people to kind of buy into this
this thing where you're like a cog
that's going to go work in a factory or
bureaucracy
and so it's uh that you know they're
there it's going to be hard to uh kind
of unwind that set of ideas within the
existing system i think we need to just
rethink it based on what was the world
look like now that the internet is kind
of
coming into its own so in a normal day
for
i don't know i think the average age of
a kid in synthesis is like 10 years old
right third fourth grade
uh when you think about their day
the kids are free to do whatever they
want for
30 minutes a day an hour a day yeah this
is crazy because
i'll tweet stuff about the the existing
system and like my
kind of problems with it i think that
you're way too nice okay you should dial
up the tweets a little bit
it does seem like the more what you call
controversial ones seem seem to do
better people you know there's at least
some people that resonate with that
but the comments i get is is crazy which
is like uh
kids need school to be socialized and i
just it hit me the other day because my
son
because we we moved during kovitz we
didn't have a lot of friends in the area
we moved in
so we put him in a school like a normal
normal kind of school it's a private
school
but even private schools go by the same
kind of logic
and he's in there and he just like you
know he he hates it he like fakes a
stomachache to like get out of going to
school
at least initially and then then he
starts kind of he starts being a little
more eager to go
and i'm like what's your why do you want
to go to school now and he's like
you know today's a pe day so we get pe
today for 30 minutes
or i want to go you know i have lunch
with my friends and there's like 30
minutes where i can like talk to my
friends
and so it just occurred to me like this
we're doing this horribly evil trick
on kids where the thing that they crave
most is like that social development
social interaction and we gate it we
give them 30 minutes a day
and then we gate it behind like sit in a
chair for another
seven hours and just kind of listen to
someone talk at you and do this work
that you're not interested in and you
don't want to do but we entice them with
like this is the only way that you can
be around other kids and it's horrible
and i think we will look back you know
once when we when we blow that system up
and we'll be like i cannot believe
that we institutionalized our children
like that i can't believe we did it
that's the way i feel
i'm gonna say this and people are gonna
get mad but that's okay uh cause i think
it to be true
schools are essentially acting as uh
the same way that a prison would act for
a non-violent offender
right meaning that there is uh
segregation of them from people that
they want to talk to hang out with
uh they are allowed to enter
interact with each other for certain
periods of time but other than that it's
basically what the
top-down kind of hierarchical structure
uh
wants them to spend their time doing so
uh in a
prison go to recess or go to the yard
go eat go here in the classroom like you
follow this very regimented
process and it's desire to engineer an
outcome right one is a control based
outcome the other is a
hopefully rehabilitation outcome it
almost feels like in some weird way what
we're doing is putting kids into the
same summer regimented
environment and we're trying to engineer
a rehabilitation of them from
a normal human and normal child and get
them to conform
to what we want them to do at the end is
that yeah crazy
to think of it that way i think i think
that's i think that's right i mean
it's important to you know realize that
there's there's this continuum right
between
individual like freedom and liberty and
kind of uh
conformity and we and we need there's
some degree of conformity that's good
right and i would just say it's uh you
know prison is kind of the extreme
end of the spectrum where you're trying
to control someone's every
movement and uh and you know you have
like kind of anarchy on the other side
which is
you know you that's not great either you
need some kind of like rules and norms
to get uh
to get things done in the world uh
there's incredible benefits to
coordination
but you know my view the schools uh
maybe you needed to do with that like to
get this industrial economy that we have
that produces
goods you know incredibly cheaply and
has raised the standard of living
globally um but now i'm not i'm not sure
we need that
i think computers have kind of taken on
a lot of like the rote repetitive work
and uh
and you know there's there are fewer
jobs where you can go be told what to do
and do it
and and like be considered to be doing a
good job and so
we need to rethink that approach like it
is it is like a a prison
in some sense and and we need to you
know i think we just need to like push
it
a little bit far in the other direction
so one thing you keep bringing up that i
think is important
is it's not so much that uh this is
broken because it's always been broken
it's almost like the goal post moved
right in terms of the skill set that's
needed the um the way
that people needed to think like all of
that has changed
and therefore you can't use the system
that got us here to get us where we need
to go
right yeah i think that's right and i
think also also
i i do think it has gotten worse like
all the teachers i talk to
they're like this has gotten worse it
wasn't it wasn't like this like 10 years
ago so you had these things where
the system starts to break down a little
bit and you'll be kind of familiar with
this with a financial system and like
bitcoin and everything
it breaks down a little bit the
authorities respond by
trying to control things even more and
so that's where you get
these you know these in in the us you
have programs that come from the
department of education
uh and they're republican they're pushed
by republicans and democrats and they're
like
raise standards let's have a common core
like let's let's let's do what we've
been doing
but let's do it better and faster and
that's made things much worse the
testing has gotten much worse
and i think that is that's a sign
that that this this kind of facade is
starting to crumble right it's like
people are aware of it the teachers are
aware of it they don't want to be doing
what they're forced to do the kids
realize this i think kids are pretty
smart they can see
they they could see that this is not
going to get them
where they want to be in life even from
a young age i really believe that they
they're just like why
why am i doing this th the world looks
nothing like what i'm doing here
even from like a really young age i
think they can tell that what's the
analogy of like sand in someone's hand
and as they go to like grab the sand it
actually pushes it out and so you start
squeezing it more and more right in the
sand
i haven't heard that um and so
i think it's important to separate like
you said the system from the people
the teachers for the most part from what
i understand and the administrators
they want to do the best they can for
the kids right they're not doing it for
the money
everybody knows like it doesn't pay a
lot of money to be a teacher
right so they're not doing it for the
money i mean you meet some people who
are just like
you know they're just phoning it in and
they're just like this is you know this
is like a job where i get summers off or
something like that right
i mean there are those people just it's
there's three million teachers in the us
right
some of them are going to be bad people
but for me like the vast majority i met
like
they want to do this because they want
to have an impact on kids they care
about kids
and they basically just don't let them
do what what they want to do like you
instead it's like you're forcing these
kids to learn math you're grading them
you're not really
you know the time to treat them as
individuals or see them as individuals
so would the teachers change the system
if they could
for the most part absolutely yeah it's a
really funny thing there's just i think
the biggest enemy
i wrote an essay about this like what
comes after the industrial education
complex
i think the biggest enemy is just
inertia i think no matter
how high you go up the chain you know
you you find very few people
who believe what we're doing now is a
good idea and that we should keep doing
it
at any level what about like the actual
education so we've talked a lot about
like structure and
regimen and uh essentially making kids
not be kids by telling them to shut up
and sit down and you know don't move and
all that stuff
uh are they actually learning important
information
like two plus two still equals four and
i think that'll happen for a long time
uh so kids need to know that right it's
like math and science to me feels like
that's like the most
objective thing in terms of uh people
think that
there's certain topics within those
disciplines that should be taught
and it's pretty easy to know hey you
either know two plus two equals four
you don't but then there's a whole bunch
of other stuff that goes into an
education
where um do we feel like
they're actually learning the
information or is it simply just
root memorization get to that final test
at the end of the year
basically regurgitate it all on the test
and then like literally
come back a month after the test and
they don't know any of it
yeah i think paul graham just i think he
pretty recently wrote an essay
about this like that you you know people
aren't learning because you study
for tests you don't need to test to just
be like okay what did you learn
over over this course right the fact
that you're studying for it
means like you don't you don't really
know it well enough in in that form and
so it's like
your mind is like a sieve like all this
information that's not relevant
just just wash it just goes right
through right
and uh yeah so that's that is going to
be very difficult to fix
in the existing system uh one of one of
the things i like to say is we
the world's like evolving you know since
we've gotten the information age
evolution
evolution of our ideas evolution of like
what's important
is taking place much faster than it ever
has
and so you know you'll see it with like
the bitcoin community these institutions
that are kind of
there they you could start an
institution and run it kind of more or
less the same way for
for you know a couple decades or like a
century and it would be all right
now things are changing much too quickly
and this this like
giant system that we have it's just not
going to be able to change
quickly enough just never going to
happen so we need like an internet
native education system something that
can change
as quickly as the world changes
something that can evolve as quickly as
the world is evolving now
so somebody else who realized this was
elon musk
walk me through the story of what was
his realizations or your understanding
of his realizations and then like what
did he do to build this school on space
spacex's campus i think it just started
with like uh
you know i don't want to i don't i don't
know his kids do well personally but i
think they're you know
you you might be able to infer that
they're they're quite intelligent right
and uh so so what would give you that
idea
so so i think that's that's not like
revealing too much to say
and uh you know he had them in the
school which was uh
which was just in a gifted school in los
angeles and was just
i think started with like an intuition
like this just isn't working like i
don't know exactly
you know what what to do but like this
isn't working and so josh our you know
co-founder of synthesis was a was a
teacher
at that school and if you can imagine
this like you're you're a teacher you
know
elon walks in like parent teacher
conference night and it's like hey
i really don't like the school i don't
think it's doing a good job you're like
sorry elon musk and uh
but he only follows us up with like
let's just do our own thing like what
would you do
if you if you know we just gave you the
resources and you could just create it
from scratch because you know what my
kids like you
like what you're doing like what would
you do you know let's and josh like
that you know that sounds amazing like a
billionaire just walked in my classroom
and said that i could start a new school
yeah and do it and you know josh has the
same point of view right he's like this
system
even when you're at this you know you
can imagine elon's got all the resources
in the world
he's got access to any school that he
wants la is one of the biggest cities in
america right
and he just can't find what he's looking
for uh because these
you know it's all kind of like the same
system they're just doing what the
public schools are doing but doing it
faster and you know
calling that innovative and so he gave
an interview with um
with chinese television vision station
you know i think that's like seven or
eight years ago now before they started
the school
and uh two two main you know elon's
famous for this first principles
approach right so those first principles
in education
are just stop doing the industrial
system thing
stop treating the kids like everybody's
going to learn the same thing at the
same time
stop segregating them by age and and
forcing them through this like linear
curriculum
so that was number one and number two
was make it
problem focused rather than tool focused
so school tends to divide things up into
subjects and they're teaching you like a
different tool
in each subject so his analogy is if
school is going to teach you to be a
mechanic or an engineer
they'd say here's a course on wrenches
here's your course on screwdrivers
and the way that you should do it is
here's an engine to take apart
all right so there's a problem how are
you going to solve it well you need to
learn how to use this tool you need to
learn how to use a screwdriver and a
wrench
and that is much more meaningful and
engaging
to kids but to to everybody like we're
engaged in problems
uh the analogy i always use like i don't
like accounting accounting is not
really attractive to me but like i know
a lot i actually actually
kind of do like it because you need to
do accounting to you need to know a
little bit
to solve this problem of like how do you
build a company how do you bring your
ideas out into the world
and so i think you know people are the
same way if you try to teach these
things in isolation
just much harder to learn it just it
doesn't stick with us
and so josh took that idea of being
problem focused
and started creating these games and
simulations because like okay what do
what are kids going to be engaged with
if you say engagement is the most
important thing
they're going to like they're like games
you know they're like simulators things
they can play with things that are like
interactive
and so he starts creating these uh for
the school
and uh and he adds this element of like
team sports to it
right so it's like you collaborate on a
team and then you're competing with the
other teams
and uh you start started operating the
school like that i think i went down in
year
year three or four to visit and um
you know it was like i'd turn the little
tour of the school and it's lunch time
we're sitting outside uh you know it's
california it's warm the kids are
playing like dodgeball
outside and then there's a group of kids
that's inside
gathered around a table like standing up
computers in front of them
and just shouting these really complex
arguments at each other
and i turned to the teacher that i was
eating with us like what's going on here
and she's like oh i'm sorry that's
that's synthesis
you know the kids get a little bit
obsessed with it i was like this is a
school thing
they've never seen kids act like this
and then what they're saying it just
sounds like really complex
they're like 10 11 12 and i'm like
they're the way they're speaking with
each other
the quality of their analysis is
you know it's equivalent to what we're
seeing in the office like building this
tech company which is like scaling
remarkably
and i and i just had this feeling like
this is
this is the future like i'm seeing the
future of education i've been to all
these schools like as part of my work at
uh
at dojo and you know i wasn't even
excited to go down to adaster cause i
was like i just i feel like i've seen it
all right
but this this thing this synthesis like
stuck with me
and you know my son was two at the time
and so when the initial kind of shock of
it wore
off my stomach just like sank because
i'm like i can't
get this for him right if you're not if
you're not a billionaire
with your own rocket company or you're
not like a rocket engineer
there's no way to get your kids in there
and even if you were an engineer at
spacex it was like a one in 25 chance
right because everybody wanted to go
there
and so i got like a little bit depressed
because i've like seen
the promised land of education there's
like no way to get to it
so i started uh i started you know josh
and i kept up like a conversation
friendship we connected over this idea
that kids crave complexity
right the what you do in school is try
to remove that complexity make
everything rules based
break it down into tiny chunks and he
was like you give them more complexity
they crave it like they want it they can
they can feel their minds like leveling
up through that
and so we kind of built a friendship and
would talk about like you know what the
future should look like
tried to get him to move to the bay area
where i live to start a school
and uh you know you're working for elon
you can't take on side projects for the
most part
um so right when the pandemic hit
actually
that kind of you know there's this wave
of like online learning people are open
to it because they you know they're
familiar with doing it
you know zoom classes at their school
and so it wasn't a thing you had to sell
people on anymore they believed that you
could learn that way even if the schools
are not doing it well
and also elon's kids finished and they
graduated the school and so
josh became like a free agent and i was
like hey like why don't we
why don't we put this online let's see
if it works online and let's see if it
works with the
kids of people who are not rocket
engineers
and uh yeah so when a kid goes in here
and i've seen it and uh
i invested in the last round today we're
gonna announce
a new round uh some big believer in this
but
what exactly do the kids do they come in
and is it on
zoom like how does the product work and
what are they doing when they're quote
unquote in class
yeah yeah it's it's a it's a little
different uh one of our our kind of
slogans is embrace the chaos so when
kids sign up we're like
you know get ready here's the zoom link
just
get ready get ready for chaos right so
they come in
and a lot of them are used to the
existing system there's
you know where there's rules there's
instructions you're kind of told what to
do
and we have a facilitator there there'd
be about 15 to 20 kids on a
on a zoom call and the facilitator is
like welcome
we've got a prop we're here to learn to
solve complex problems together that's
the critical skill
that's what we're going to teach you
guys so you can build the future
whatever it looks like and we're going
to put you in breakout rooms on teams
and you're going to have a problem to
solve figure it out and then every hand
goes up and they're like what what's the
problem like
what do we what do we do exactly what
are the rules what am i not allowed to
do
we're gonna give you the problem it's
gonna be chaos and you're gonna figure
it out to put them in the breakout rooms
there's a there's a game like uh or
simulation that kind of comes up on the
screen
and they've got to figure it out and
it's uh
and it's crazy it's chaotic our first
couple sessions we had kids uh
some of the kids would like be in tears
because it was so frustrating
um but then they they get through it and
they figure it out
and it builds this confidence where like
you took on the unknown you took on the
chaotic
and you made sense of it and you figured
it out and now you just want more and so
those are the parents that write to us
the kids that were like the most upset
the parents are right to us and be like
this has changed her mentality now like
she's now when she's these problems
she's like she's attacking them she's on
offense like she's not afraid anymore
like it's pretty incredible that you can
do this just through these like
simulations on zoom but it's uh you know
it mirrors life right
the legacy system that we talked about
in the beginning is all about root
memorization
no critical thinking no problem solving
like literally
sit down shut up don't move two plus two
equals four okay end of year what's two
plus two equal four great job go to the
next grade
you know what's crazy by the way is that
when i visited so many classrooms and uh
my realization was that i think kids are
learning
about 30 minutes a week
if you go to school for you know like 35
hours or so
i think they learn what they could learn
in 30 minutes i think it takes
a week to give them 30 minutes yeah i
know that sounds extreme
but you know if you're if you have kids
and they're doing like zoom calls
just go listen in on the zoom calls or
or
go see if they'll let you visit the
classroom and look at what they're doing
and i that that's like my i've been to a
ton of clients i'm talking not talking
about like only like really
you know kind of underfunded public
schools i'm talking about like private
schools like top-notch public schools
the kids learn very very very little
in school so anyway i wanted to
interject that that's good carry on
because the exact opposite of that is
what synthesis is doing which is saying
see the idea we don't care if you know
what two plus two equals four
is in terms of like the memorization
what we want to do is give you a problem
and by the way if at
any point you have to do math you're
going to figure it out because you need
the math to solve the problem
right and it's much more focused on this
like problem solving
critical thinking independent thought
leadership
communication uh teamwork like you know
i could go on and on and on and this
litany of
uh different skill sets that i'm gonna
describe sound a whole hell of a lot
like what
anybody who runs a business wants to
hire for right it's somebody who's got
problem solving complex uh thinking
skills you know first principles
leadership teamwork communication et
cetera
and so just on the face of like the
structure it's complexity right it's
that industrial systems you're trying to
simplify things so that humans can act
as parts
in this in this bigger machine the
machine itself is complex though
and now i think you know where the world
is going is like the
the more you're able to handle
complexity to manage complexity to
manage to make sense out of chaos to
synthesize
you know those are those are the
valuable jobs that's the
that's the valuable skill is humanity's
most valuable skill
working together to solve complex
problems that's elon's the canonical
example right he's
and it's good at individual level and
good for the civilization
elon you know arguably has done more for
to move civilization forward than
anybody
alive and and he's also you know the
richest man like kind of incidentally
right so it's a it's the most valuable
skill i would argue that you can give to
your kids
and and if enough people do this it will
actually move the civilization forward
like we will be able to accelerate
human progress so
what i think has blown me away is you
can design all the best games you can
get kids to
sign up you can build a great business
whatever
it's hearing the kids talk these kids
talk better than literally people i
worked with at facebook 100
right and when i first started talking
to you
you said something to me and i didn't
believe you you said that you took
some kids from synthesis who had played
these complex games and you put them in
competition with i think it was berkeley
computer science
kids uh engineering engineering graduate
students
okay oh engineering graduates so even
better than mechanical
engineering or something like that yeah
and they played these games
and it was a slaughter yeah this was a
massacre
but it wasn't in favor of the
engineering graduate students it was in
favor of 10 12
you know 13 year old kids yeah why is
that why is it that somebody who has
reached the pinnacle of the traditional
education system and
you know by all uh kind of traditional
metrics has you know
achieved everything because what are you
good at right if you're if you're if
you've done really well in that system
what are you good at
it's not necessarily solving complex
problems in chaotic environments
quite the opposite you're really good at
following the rules and solving these
problems that are scoped for you and so
they have the same problem that kids
have
you know when they're transitioning into
synthesis for the first time
is they're used to the way things
working being like let's be told what to
do
you know get the right answer on this
and with the chaotic environment with no
one
which is the way life works right no no
one can really tell you precisely the
rules or precisely like
how to win the game of life like you
need to figure that out
for yourself and so the kids who've gone
through synthesis they're they're used
to that and these
you know people who are at the pinnacle
of the existing system are are kind of
you know they're they're the opposite it
almost is exactly what paul graham's
talking about with like learning to
unlearn
right and his whole thing i think is uh
i think use the example of y combinator
when people show up who are really good
at school they say to paul like
hey what do i do to fundraise right and
what they're expecting him to say is
okay send 100 emails
have 20 meetings say you know this
script
and then you get a million dollar
investment and say okay thank you paul
right and they go and they
100 meetings or 100 emails whatever and
they go through the system
instead what he says is like no like
dummy
right like that's not the way to do it
instead the way to do it is like build a
product that works
right and like that people want and then
like every investor will come to you and
they'll be knocking down your door to
give you money
and so it's very much like a
prescriptive
type you know again just root
memorization
here's what to do go follow the rules
and do it versus
actually getting at from a first
principle standpoint
what is the goal of the investors and
what is going to elicit their
interest and so he says that a lot of
times people are good at school have to
unlearn
what they've learned over the last
however many years it feels like you
guys are almost getting to the kids
before they actually learn some of that
stuff
right you're almost like cutting them
off and saying hey before you go down
this path
and get you know uh kind of
indoctrinated into the industrial
education system
yeah we're going to teach you a
different way and kids really gravitate
towards that
yeah i think that's right i think we're
i think it
it's a little bit of like dose of
freedom and the kind of
confidence you get from like whoa no one
told me the answer i just figured
out that out and then you get the metal
lesson well i can just figure things out
on my own
that's crazy basically just grinds that
idea out of us and it takes a long time
because it's really
counter to human nature and you give
kids a little bit of dose of like how
things could be
and and that that sticks that i think i
think even just a little bit
might be enough inoculation against the
kind of indoctrination that you'll get
in school
to keep your keep your mind open and
just just internalize the idea
that you can solve problems and this is
this is what innovative people do
they figure things out for themselves
they figure out how the game works on
their own and they figure out how to
how to break the rules in a way that
benefits other people and that's that's
what we want more of that's what society
needs more of
so this works
and as the founder you can't say that i
can say that as an investor
and we can just use metrics to prove it
right
so you have the idea once the pandemic
kind of hits you guys do a little
testing
you really launch the subscription-based
product that we know today
in november of 2020 yep yep
first week in november yeah okay so
november 2020
how long does it take you from november
to a million dollars in annualized
revenue
i think it's i think we hit it uh you
know like december 31st so like about
two months okay so two months from zero
to a million dollars an arr
if we then look and uh you raised a
seed round right and uh
it was myself others i don't know who
wants to be said who not
pomp and friends yeah let's say some
some friends some of you will know
uh but all individual checks yeah
and then we announce it we did it a very
specific way
we'll talk about that in a second you
now
fast forward to uh may are now doing
over three million dollars in annualized
revenue
that's all right so when you do that
you've raised five million dollars
series a
50 million dollar post money valuation
yeah
and when we look at this
why is it that you're able to go from
zero to
millions of dollars of annual recurring
revenue
in such a short period of time when it
seems like every other business in the
world
struggles to find product market fit and
scale revenue
like that all happened in six months
and you're very quickly continuing to
scale and sign up more people
like why is it working well on the
product market fit side i mean you have
to remember
josh has been a teacher for 10 years
it's actually kind of rare for
an edtech startup to have it as an
experienced teacher and like a founder
role from from the outset and what was
he doing
he's he's inventing new things for elon
school so for seven of those years you
know he's working for elon which is
pretty uh
pretty hardcore job right like you're
you're you know you get a lot of anxiety
and you're just trying to you make sure
that you keep that job and like and do a
great job with it
so for seven years he's running these
like experiments with the kids there and
refining the ideas and he's got this you
know the intuition
about about what kids need and and want
and so
it's uh we did not we didn't not exactly
start
you know just just six months ago we had
all that background knowledge and then
the challenge is like translating that
to an online
environment right taking it from in
person kind of like
on on paper you may be using excel
spreadsheets to keep score to like put
it put it online into software
um so that's the first part of that and
then second you know i think we go back
before
november we um anna anna for fabrega
um joined us she's uh she's our chief
evangelist and she's got this you know
i think the world's biggest twitter
following may be focused on
new ways to to educate kids so she was a
teacher
as well i spent four years as a teacher
you know face to face with kids every
day you get that
intuition for what works when you do
that and when she we met on twitter
brought her in to check out some of the
sessions and she was like wow like
this is this is it so she wrote like a
thread about the company announcing it
on twitter
that brought this info influx of
customers that's how we got from zero to
to a million in the first two months
and also you know connected with with
you
which is uh which was which is you know
just just kind of move
access to more of these like networks of
people on twitter so
i think it's like if you were gonna do
this and you're gonna go sell it to
schools and sell it to the existing
system
one of the problems is you know the the
as much as the administrators like
district administrators would want to do
the right thing for kids you know it's
they don't have the same
kind of uh anxiety that a parent has
right like if you're sending your kids
to school and you feel like
this is not the right way to educate
your kids you're looking for something
else and you're eager
for solutions for that and so when we
tap into these networks on twitter it's
you know people who follow you or people
who follow anna they're looking for new
ways to do things they're used to
turning to the internet to solve their
problems and just
get the right thing out in front of them
they're like it clicks and uh
off to the races i want to talk about
fundraising strategy
um as far as i know you have zero
institutional venture investors
in the company we have a little um we
have uh sam teller who's elon's former
chief of staff during during like the
model three
days which had to be one of the craziest
jobs in the world um so he's
he's a venture partner in their val he
works at valor and it's a valor venture
partners are in but like as not as part
of the fund right as like
seed you know angels effectively so yeah
apart from that
all angels okay and the reason why i
think you and i
kind of saw eye to eye almost
immediately i think we literally had
like a five minute conversation we're
like yeah we shouldn't take any venture
money we should just go take it from you
you just ruin you ruin us on traditional
vc's right because we're like call you
and you're like all right like how much
how much you need i'm like well you know
we're we're looking to do x and you're
like okay
done like send me the paperworks i'll
sign i'll give you the money and it's
like all right
and also by the way here's a bunch of my
friends who are going to invest too and
are going to help you
with the narrative so it's uh it'll be
tough to go back so
we essentially have prioritized people
with
i would categorize it as three things
people who co-invested in this round
are folks with large online audiences
yep have very specific companies that
they have built and run
that have very large distribution or are
very well versed usually as founders
in things that you as a ceo as you
continue to build the business are going
to go through
yep and so it feels like
distribution was never a thing that
investors brought to the table now they
do
advice usually was but it usually wasn't
directly from the
investor in many cases a lot of times
i'm just connecting you to these people
yeah and then when it came to hiring and
these other things it was just a numbers
game like hey how do we get you in front
of enough candidates and you
find the best one you hired and so it
almost feels like in some weird way
because now all of these people either
have personal capital or they have their
own like angel funds or whatever
uh we've been able to assemble how many
investors from this last round
oh i think it's something something like
45.
all right so 45 people give or take plus
or minus 10 or 15. not either side
45 people that as we announced it today
are likely to drive way more impact than
what a traditional venture investor
could do yep
is this gonna just be the norm or is it
specific to companies
like yours that are consumer focused
that have a very
kind of um outlier type story where it's
when people hear it just like oh of
course like that's a thing um
and so you kind of need almost like a
company's product market fit here you
almost need like investor
product fit and so your company is
specifically
aligned with this type of strategy
whereas others might not be
yeah i think i think that that's right i
mean it's of course the story the back
story
is is helpful for attracting attention
um but we were inspired by
um by primarily mateo at eight sleep
and what they'd done on on twitter to
promote the product and then austin
allred at lambda school and
they're both investors in this round now
um so you could
you could see what they'd done you could
see that it worked it's it's uh
you know you're effectively uh we
we cannot always as humans just like
think through everything
from principles ourselves we have to
rely on people that we trust and so you
can think of
the kind of shorthand for the round is
like who has trust
at scale like it's not it's not that you
have an audience
that's so valuable it's that you have an
audience
who trusts you so and you you have skin
in the game you cannot
mislead them you'll lose your audience
or they're not going to follow you
anywhere
so you have the skin in the game and all
the other investors who have audience
they have this skin in the game where
like if they're recommending
something to you right it's it's
something that they actually believe in
because the incentives are aligned there
and it's you know i just think it's the
most obvious thing in the world these
vcs are essentially selling
cash which is a commodity and it's not
scarce the scarce thing is
that trust at scale and so vcs are sort
of getting unbundled the same way the
education system
is going to get unbundled and uh you
know it's a
it's an interesting kind of new world i
don't think we're going to be the last
company to uh to do it this way i think
this is going to be the norm
uh i'm betting my career that you're not
going to be here
um i think another interesting part of
this i don't want to say any names
they can say if they want uh is we've
got some
very very helpful venture capital
investors they just did it personally
rather than through their funds
and that was kind of the thought process
right was they individually could be
very helpful let's get them in
the fund itself is almost added
bureaucracy that's unnecessary
yeah i think that's right i mean i just
think increasingly
people don't know who the who the vc
funds
those those names don't matter as much
as the individuals or the individuals
if you look at people who have companies
and then like the founders on twitter or
you know the principals are on twitter
uh it's the person that gets most of the
attention right people want to connect
with people not
institutions and so that's uh you know i
to me it doesn't seem like particularly
insightful you can just look at twitter
and like see what's going on it just
feels like the most obvious thing in the
world to me
um there's another factor with us
specifically where we've been cash flow
positive like pretty much since the
beginning like i started off i wasn't
sure if it was going to be
yes we didn't know like it's only like
rocket engineers kids
doing this in the in the whole world
like 30
hand-picked like rocket engineers kids
and so i'm like i just have no idea
if this is gonna be like a a venture bus
like is this going to is this something
that's for everybody we had no clue so i
kind of like funded it myself initially
and wasn't didn't want to raise the
money because didn't want that
pressure before we kind of figured out
the shape of this thing and so that
helped because we were cash flow
positives when we go to raise money
it's not about the money like we we
would have gotten you on the cap table
for free
you only told me that after i had signed
i mean the money's nice but it's it's
you know it's basically so the seed
round has sat in the bank and like we've
you know we've got a little bit more
money than uh than we originally raised
because it wasn't about the money like
you
cannot buy the kind of like the kind of
trust like the kind of audience
um that you have and that some of our
other investors have right it's it's
much more like a world based on trust
and i think it's a
that's more honest like truthful world
to live in and yeah i'm excited about it
i think either the first or second call
we ever had you literally
told me you're never going to raise
money and i was like all right i don't
have to convince this guy to raise any
money
like that like usually founders are like
begging for money right they're like
you know i'm gonna raise a ton of money
and you were just like yeah we don't
need the money like
we're profitable like this thing's just
gonna go um
and so i think that like it's very
obvious look the product
the way that you're approaching the
education like everything is very
different
the fundraising strategy's been very
different uh we can
layer in one other aspect that's very
different which is the way that
we've announced this stuff so in the
seed round did you talk to any reporters
or was it just the investor base and
podcast essentially that did all the
distribution yeah i didn't even consider
it that's kind of i think you you
brought it up
one time or maybe maybe a little bit
after the seed round like all right
we'll get some mainstream press
i think i was like why why is it
and you can see right like because i
don't we should share this chart right
i've texted it to you and texted some of
the other investors there's like
there's the pomp effect right where i
show people the graph
and i'm like tell me where pom made his
announcement it's like the most obvious
just this massive spike that's like
you know it spikes and then it comes
down but it's at a permanent
higher level right and it's it's
completely insane whenever i show it to
people they're like
yeah wow okay like traditional vcs or no
there's no one that's going to be able
to do this for you
it it's um austin reef uh yeah
who is an investor uh texted me i guess
you had sent him the chart
and all he responded i think uh was
he said saw the chart lol right just
like
it is crazy just like okay like yeah
this works
and i think part of it also you go back
to like this trust aspect
is when you lose control of the
narrative
you actually can lose control of the
trust with the
audience or with the potential customer
base as well right because to me it's uh
you get one shot
in hey here's what it is here's how it
works
here's why you should care and actually
that's not
what the goal of traditional press is
traditional press is you're trying to
get legitimacy
right the distribution comes with the
legitimacy but you're trying to get
validation and legitimacy and hey we
were featured in x or y publication
yeah but i think you're right in that
like
on the internet would you rather get
featured in a mainstream press
or mentioned by the person in your
industry who's got the largest audience
and the most trust with that
it's actually almost like that
individual now is the same thing as like
the trade publication used to be
right like they have the audience and
they have the trust
and the engagement and therefore if you
look at it almost like rather than just
general distribution but targeted
distribution
yeah they have more targeted
distribution than the mainstream
yeah the mainstream is like i mean i
don't i don't think i read i don't read
anything in the mainstream
except like people post on twitter to
like dunk on it and
show you how they're lying or like
misinformed right so
there's this uh audience there's kind of
like a
psychological alignment with the
audience which i i i wasn't sure
when we when we brought you on as a seed
investor like i knew anna's audience
like it's okay people who are interested
in
the future of education like i think
that's going to work pretty well to
drive in customers but what about an
audience is primarily like investors
like bitcoiners
but i i had the hypothesis that you know
bitcoin is like
there's just energy behind disrupting
this legacy
financial system so you you kind of have
to be you know
a free thinker to uh to to consider
you know if you don't trust the banks
you definitely don't trust the exactly
exactly
exactly that's the most succinct way to
put it right so
so i thought there might be some
psychological alignment with the
audience there and that's uh
you know that that's proven right and
those are the people we want like we
don't want the people who are like uh
you know when's the test can you give my
kid a grade on this can you
you know can you make it basically more
like this the principles of this
existing system
like we don't we're not gonna do that
and josh been really helpful there
because he's used to dealing with like
people who who want that like very
wealthy people who are like you know
wanting to do things a certain way and
he's just used to being like it's not
the place for you
right like you you can join or you
cannot join i don't care but like we're
going to do it this way and by this is
the way elon wants it done so like if
you don't want it that way
then you go do your own thing that's
fine
when you think about where this is going
uh
right now most of the students not all
of them but most of them are between the
ages of
let's call it eight and 14 based in the
united states or north america is that
fair to categorize at all most okay yeah
the students from all over the world i
was gonna say there are students though
uh when i made the seed investment
announcement i literally had a
dad who messaged me from india
and said my kid is in the course and uh
i love it this is amazing right and i
remember thinking to myself
based on when i know the courses are run
that's not a normal time that a kid is
awake in india right no
yeah yeah that's right and so like it's
just a date it's just one
piece of data out of a whole plethora of
them but this idea that like wait a
second
this is so important that kids are
staying up or waking up early or
whatever to go do this in other parts of
the world
makes me think that actually if you can
figure out logistically you can go
serve a very high percentage of
children in the world with this type of
education
and you don't have to replace school it
can just be supplemental for a very long
period of time
but from a pure like roi
you're going to get way more out of this
than you are in a traditional education
system is that
fair to categorize how you think about
it
yeah i think you know josh one of his
principles is like you
you kids have a limited amount of time
just like anybody else if you're going
to
you know if you're going to do something
for their education you'll be the best
possible use
of their time right if you if you do
that um
throughout their kind of childhood
they're just going to be in a much
better position compared if you do
something where it's like
sitting in a desk and you're you're
wasting hours and you're not learning
anything useful like
it's it's criminal when you really think
about it i
really do think this is you know you
might disagree you might hit the
financial system
but i think this industrial education
system is the single largest
bottleneck holding back human progress i
think people in the future are going to
look back and be like
i cannot believe we institutionalized
kids this way
and as you said it's it's it's global
right
different places they have different
school systems but they're all for the
most part kind of built on this
industrial model and any your audience
is from all over the world
and and our customers are from all over
the world and uh i don't know if we're
talking about the same guy but that's
there's at least one parent in india
that's like yeah this kid wakes up at 4
30 a.m
and i'm not forcing him to do it he's
just like i really want to be in
synthesis i'll get up at 4 30 a.m
before school and and take the synthesis
courses so
that's it's pretty amazing for people to
have that kind of excitement about it
there are two problems in the world
today that every
other problem can be drawn back to and
it's
money and education and that's it
and the people who control or influence
the money system
are super bureaucratic frankly they are
full of [ __ ] as a system and their
internet has exposed them
yep the system
that teaches education is super
bureaucratic
they're full of [ __ ] right and the
internet has exposed them
and what i think we're getting is we're
essentially getting um disruption
in a very unique way because i think
that what
really made me be you know kind of so
positive on this and just like yes this
is a a solution i don't have to be the
solution but a solution yeah
is you can look at the school system and
you can be like this is broken
and you can do one of two things you can
be the victim
or you can be the person on offense
trying to fix something
right and a lot of parents i think
actually like just go search it on
twitter like i literally did it i went
and i searched and like school sucks
right like type that in twitter you will
find a bunch of
parents being like school sucks right my
kid doesn't learn anything or like you
know you just go use these phrases
and then you're like okay well what are
you doing about it and to me it's almost
worse like they know that it doesn't
work
but they're not doing anything and some
of them just don't have another option
right like literally that's what they
have to do they have to go to work
they don't have any other options in
their hometown whatever it's hard i mean
even even for me like we've we
were you know we're doing fine
financially my wife uh you know is a
stay-at-home mother
and so we've got the time and the
resources to figure this out and and
it's hard
it's still hard completely agree but
you josh others are choosing to go do
something about it
right and i think that like that's where
you actually get solutions the
other thing actually almost makes it um
more bureaucratic in a way
because now a school spends you know
what used to be one percent of their
time dealing with like customer
complaints or like parent complaints
now it's three percent of their time
five percent like at some point it's
actually 20
of the school administrators time is
spent with like parents complaining that
it doesn't work
and it redirects energy from actually
like teaching the kids
whereas with this you basically just say
hey we have a different option like
you know don't complain like vote with
your feet and vote with your dollars
just blashy who says
i think yeah biology's like concept of
of exit is like something i think about
a lot
i'm calling this like the there's sort
of like a soft exit from the system
right now
where you know there's myself included
for this year like we have our have our
one child in a traditional school um
but you know i i tell them just like
don't you know bring a book
and like read when they're doing the
lessons like so you can get something
out of it and then we'll do synthesis
and we'll learn like there's no way i'm
leaving
your learning your cognitive development
up to just
who happened the people who happen to
live you know within a 30-mile radius
of our home like the the best of the the
best is gonna be
on the internet and like that's that's
what i want you doing so
i i do think that that's kind of like
how things are to evolve there's
obviously
it's important to get kids together in
person
but what's really exciting is if you
unbundle these things you can get them
together in person to be
kids like school could just be recess
like four or five hours a day
i think that'd be fine if you then spend
some time
reading some time doing things like
synthesis that are really kind of
compressing your the time that you're
spending like
focused on learning specifically just
just compress that time and uh and then
you've got time to be a kid time to
explore
like all the things that we want our our
kids to do
um so yeah it's crazy to think about how
different the world would look
if everyone was able to learn
independent thinking problem solving
critical thinking skills
early rather than 90 plus percent of
society literally just being told
what to do and what to think and not how
to think it's impossible to imagine i
mean literally impossible to imagine
right because all these kids like some
people their
psyche kind of survives the existing
system like you
you survive with some innovative ability
intact and like obviously people do
right but it's it was a nightmare for
the teachers that dealt with me while i
was in school
yeah yeah me too i i feel bad for uh for
a lot of the trouble i caused in school
but uh
but but yeah you know some people kind
of you know they're able to maintain
that kind of spirit if you like human
ingenuity in spite of the system like
what if you have a system that
encourages that well you literally can't
imagine
when you start getting you know a
million kids a year like educated in
this way or
10 million 100 million the things that
they will create
to improve the society literally
unimaginable
yeah incredibly exciting time to be
alive
you have three children that's right
what age there's seven almost five and
almost two all right two older ones are
boys are you gonna take them out of
traditional education
and put them in synthesis exclusively is
that a possibility in the future that
synthesis is a replacement or does it
stay supplemental like how do you just
think about
the evolution of this yeah we're
exploring it so
i like i announced this on twitter that
my oldest who's uh
who's seven is going we we you know
cancelled the uh
tuition for the following year and he's
doing synthesis with uh
we call it synthesis junior so it's like
six and seven year olds it's
traditionally been you know only
only up you know age eight so we're
experimenting with doing a little bit
younger
um we had i think 1300 applications for
for about 15 spots when we put this out
on twitter
and i just kind of told everybody like
all right you know look skin in the game
like i'm burning the boats behind us
like this is
this is how i'm gonna educate my kids so
you can at least know if you enroll your
kids like it's
i'm not selling you something that i
don't believe
in myself like this is my kids are gonna
be in this so
i'm paying attention to it right i'm
paying attention to the experience
and uh and yeah it's uh we don't have it
figured out yet but it's uh
but it's thrilling and i think there
will be there would be at least some
part of synthesis like anybody can do
for like an hour or two a week
and then there'll be some part of it
that's like uh more like a full stack
online school
you're not going to want to answer this
but would we be better
off like does school do more damage than
does good
the traditional like industrial
education system
is it a net positive or net negative for
students
compared to what right i mean like
there's i think if maybe you just uh
you know you just let kids roam free on
the streets is that going to be better
like probably in some places that'd be
better and probably in some places
that's going to be worse so i
you know you're always trying to wear
things the real question is
like can can we do better is there going
to be progress
or is this just the way things are and i
think
what i tend to think about there is uh
there's this idea like the lindy effect
right so the ideas that have been around
for a while will tend to survive
a little like a while longer new ideas
will
you know just statistically are more
likely to die out quickly i think it's
important people realize the system is a
hundred years old
that's it it's not been like this for
all of human history it's a hundred
years old
and you know maybe i think it probably
passed the midpoint of its usefulness
maybe sometime in like the 1960s 1970s
and i think it's like on the decline now
so i think we're
we're going to see progress like and
it's funny like even silicon valley like
investors are supposed to be
investing in the future will have this
idea that like no
it just it just feels like same way the
financial system feels it's like it's
going to be this way
forever because you grew up with it that
way but if you take a longer view
historically
this is this is unnatural it's it's a
new idea that we should
you know segregate kids by age and have
them learn as if they were machines
and it's not going to last so i think
there's going to be progress and uh
yeah i just thought of this idea so i'm
just gonna say it
we should live stream me playing against
some of the kids
and see who wins and i say live stream
because
if i lose i'll never admit it so you'll
at least have it so other people know
but i think like that is part of it
right is that's how you teach people
like this works
is yeah you could literally bring in
like bring in the venture capitals who
thinks it doesn't work but like cool
play the 13 year old
yeah right yeah 13 year old smokes you
you're going to walk away with your
pride kind of hurt a little bit but also
like
oh wait maybe my kids should be in this
well it's this is why we start with
younger kids right so something i think
about pretty often is
there aren't any there aren't
world-class athletes or musicians who
start
like in their 20s right but that's the
way
all of us are when we start you know if
you're starting like building companies
or innovating
creating things like most of us just the
early part of our life
is just it's just kind of wasted and
then we have to pick it up later
and uh you know the your your brain and
your body just don't
they don't adjust the same way after
after childhood like adolescence like
there's famously like you
if you don't acquire language by a
certain age like you you can't do it
right so your brain is more plastic
so it's kind of like frightening that
these kids are kind of like uh
they're raised in complexity if you're
going through synthesis like you're
they're this is just gonna be the norm
for them and the more complex we make it
it's kind of like this in ender's game
like they
they keep uh increasing the difficulty
of the games until the kids are just
like
way beyond what the adults could do
because they realize
you know the kids brains are more
plastic they can they can pick up the
new ways
quicker than we can so it's compounding
too right like that's right i think if
you take
two you know eight-year-olds and you
start them out
in year one and the eight-year-old that
goes through synthesis
is five percent better than the
eight-year-old who went through the
traditional system
okay it's five percent some people are
like who cares right but if you
extrapolate that out and that continues
right and you get compounding in
synthesis that you don't get in the kind
of traditional system
by the time they're 15 that's not even
like that's the difference between
harvard and community college right like
i mean
in the old system like that's literally
the complete opposite ends of the
spectrum
yeah on just pure time and kind of
persistence
in a different system that ends up being
better yeah and i think that's this is
we're going to start sharing more of
this stuff like we've
brought on this new round of investors
we've got kind of like a good a good
solid platform to reach people
uh we've shared just like one video so
far of a 10 year old called
emmett right he's only he's been in
sentences for like six months right he's
not not like
and he sounds better than a lot of
people on twitter yeah
and the comment we get a lot is like
well you've just uh
this is like just some some rich kid or
something like so this is like they
picked like a cherry genius kid like
like no you just you have no idea
what kids are capable of and we're gonna
start putting more of this stuff out
there from a variety of kids like
we're you know we're not cherry-picking
it's just that you know
they they pick things up quickly and if
you give them that uh that sort of like
playground for the mind
to to play around and they stay engaged
with that the results are
are shocking and that's what i saw when
i was at astra i was seeing these kids
in like
year four of doing synthesis and i was
just like what
the hell is going on like i i couldn't
imagine it
um i remember sending sending some like
audio of that
to my friend and him being like these
are these are like second year law
students really
there's no way these are like 12 13 year
olds and just like literally just
couldn't believe it
and uh yeah it's that that's that
compounding effect right
i think that it is exactly what the
world needs which is why i'm excited to
invest and i think the craziest part for
me is
like forget all the company building
stuff forget all of
um the like excitement around uh
building a team
and scaling it and all that it's just
like when you teach kids this like even
if you said to me hey we're only going
to teach 100 kids that's all we're ever
going to be able to impact
there's a very good probability those
100 kids go on to do some pretty crazy
[ __ ] in the world
that we all end up pointing at and being
like you know what like that person's
special
and it's not because you're doing
anything uh
or you've got some special power you're
just literally teaching them a different
way of thinking that actually ends up
lending itself to
being very very effective in this kind
of chaotic uncertain you know problem
ridden world and so in some crazy way
i think most people are going to make
the mistake of evaluating the
value and the impact of synthesis from
how much money do you make how many
students came through the program like
whatever
but instead you can look at it as like
what is the increase
in productivity in the world from the
students that went through the program
and we won't know that for a long time
but if it goes the right way
you know if the next elon musk goes
through the program
and you end up you know building a very
very successful business is it more
important that the business was
successful or the next elon musk was
taught how to think the right way and
do it like actually the student's impact
is going to be
you know it's going to way outweigh
anything that a business can do by
itself
yeah absolutely i think all of our other
problems
are downstream of education right so if
you can fix that
you can solve you know clean energy
access to clean water we can get flying
cars finally we can get uh
we could all all in the future can be um
can be amazing and like kind of
unlimited in in infinite ways and it's
it's
like things have gotten better in human
society
over the centuries since since the
enlightenment began and
you know we can we can improve on that
though we're not we're not done like
things can improve
in a limitless fashion and i completely
agree with what you what you say about
like the
the value of it is in we don't this the
go back to what i said earlier solving
complex problems together that's what
makes humans unique that is the most
valuable skill
we know there's some general component
to it because people like elon or like
jack dorsey
can succeed in multiple domains we don't
know how to confer
that skill or cultivate it at scale yet
and if we can figure that out it's to me
it's like a game changer for human
society it'll be like a before and after
moment
bitcoiners like to say fix the money fix
the world synthesis may just start
saying fix the education fix the world
it's basically the same thing that's
right all right where can we send people
if you're if you've got a kid between
the ages of what eight and 14
uh you can you can so you can apply now
if you're if you're six
six or seven but there's just know that
there's like a wait list so if you want
to get in
that i'd recommend like going ahead and
getting your application in now and
we'll be accepting on a rolling basis
but yeah if you're
between 8 and 14 you can uh you can
enroll um there's a little bit of a
waitlist but you'll get in fairly
quickly
and the website is synthesis.is
synthesis.is
that's right all right go sign up and
when they ask you where you found it
say pomp just so they keep thinking that
i'm smart even though they're doing all
the hard work
and then they call this big spike that
has nothing to do with me but yeah i
appreciate the credit
and then where can people find you on
twitter uh twitter i'm
at chrismanfrank awesome thank you
please keep going
thank you thanks for the help